During lopsided games or pauses in action,
it is the sports team’s mascot that keeps
fans entertained.
Be it with dancing, shooting t-shirts into
the crowds or goading opposing coaches into
attacking them, mascots make sports a little
more fun – even if a few of them gives kids
nightmares.
While we tend to think of mascots as distinctly
American, even the San Diego Chicken can trace
his origins to 19th century France.
You see, the word “mascot” probably derives
from the French word “mascoto,” meaning
“witch, fairy or sorcerer.”
This, in turn, gave rise to the slang word
“mascotte,” meaning “talisman” or
“sorcerer’s charm” in the 1860s.
It was often used in the context of gambling,
in hopes that a “mascotte” was there to
pull luck to the bettor’s side.
The word was first popularized and brought
to the mainstream by the 1880s French opera
“La Mascotte,” written by playwright Edmond
Audran.
The opera was about an Italian farmer whose
crops just wouldn’t grow- that is, until
he’s visited by a mysterious virgin named
Bettina who, as long as she remains a virgin,
functions as something of a good luck charm.
With her help, his fortunes soon turn around.
It’s hard to decipher who – or what – was
the first sports mascot.
According to esteemed etymologist Barry Popik,
the word “mascotte” was first used in
the context of a good luck charm in sporting
events around the 1880s in American baseball.
According to The Dickson Baseball Dictionary,
the first use of it was in an 1883 issue of
The Sporting Life about a boy named “Chic,”
who carried bats and ran errands for the players.
Beyond his practical usefulness, the players
also considered him a good luck charm.
As Sporting Life wrote, “the players pin
their faith to (Chic’s) luck-bringing qualities.”
As for the first animal mascots (of sorts),
in an 1884 edition of the Cincinnati Enquirer,
seemingly in regards to a goat wandering around
their baseball team, there is this line, “The
goat was probably looking for some show-bills,
oyster-cans, or some other usually palatable
dish for his stomach, but the audience could
not see it in that light, and thought he was
even a better ‘Mascotte’ than the old-time
favorite.”
In an 1884 issue of Sporting Life, there’s
also a reference to a mascot involved in the
Boston’s baseball team recent ability to
win games, “Have the Bostons a Mascotte?
They have crawled out some very small holes
the past two weeks.”
Two years later, Sporting Life again connected
the word to being a good luck charm, but dropped
the “e” getting us closer to the modern
day spelling- “Little Nick is the luckiest
man in the country, and is certainly the Browns’
mascott.”
williehahnIn 1886, the New York Times dropped
the extra “t,” marking the first known
time the modern word “mascot” is used.
The reference was about a boy named Charle
Gallagher who was “said to have been born
with teeth and is guaranteed to possess all
the magic charms of a genuine mascot.”
In yet another 1886 reference that used the
modern spelling, The Chicago Tribune noted
on June 18th of that year,
(T)he Chicago players and their mascot marched
down the platform and placed themselves at
the head of the double column of visiting
Chicagoans that had formed at the depot, and
then with their brooms elevated, the delegation
marched out of the depot…The odd looking
procession, extending nearly two squares,
attracted a vast amount of attention….
[They] were escorted to the ground by a band,
and entered the field behind little Willie
Hahn, who carried an immense broom on which
were the words ‘Our Mascot.’
In any event, in late 19th century and into
the early part of the 20th century, it appears
that all sports mascots were children or real
animals and, contrary to the version of the
mascot we have today, they were taken very
seriously.
For instance, the 1888 St. Louis Browns’
team photo featured a little, uniformed boy
and two dogs, all three given ample credit
for being part of the team that was nicknamed
the “World Beaters.”
The first football mascot may have been Handsome
Dan, a bulldog that belonged to a member of
the Yale class of 1892.
126 years later – and 17 bulldogs (as of
this writing, the university is searching
for the 18th) – Handsome Dan is still Yale’s
mascot, with a statute and a Shake Shack hot
dog to his name.
The 1919 Chicago White Sox credited a physically
disabled orphan named Eddie Bennett for providing
them enough luck to win the American League
pennant.
This was the same year of the infamous “Black
Sox” scandal involving several players on
the team conspiring with gamblers to intentionally
throw the World Series.
Unfortunately for the rest of the team, Bennett’s
luck couldn’t overcome their efforts.
As for the professional mascots we have today,
the first sports mascot that made a career
out of it (in other words, wasn’t a kid
or an animal) is generally thought to be Max
Patkin, known as the “Clown Prince of Baseball.”
Patkin began his mascot career as an actual
baseball player, pitching for a White Sox
minor league team.
He ended up on a Navy team during World War
II and once, during an exhibition in Hawaii,
he found himself pitching to the great Joe
DiMaggio.
Legend has it that Patkin served up a pitch
that the Yankee Clipper hammered for a home
run.
On a whim as DiMaggio rounded the bases, Patkin
followed.
Mocking his trot and making goofy faces- the
crowd loved it.
Such antics were not unheard of back then.
For instance, Major League Baseball player
Herman “Germany” Schaefer once stepped
up to bat wearing a raincoat and galoshes,
along with carrying an umbrella to hit with
instead of a bat- he was hinting to the umpire
that maybe they should call the game due to
the rain…
You can read more about his many antics here:
There Once was a Major League Baseball Player
Who Stole First From Second.
As for Patkin, his playful mockery of DiMaggio
began a nearly five-decade career entertaining
baseball crowds.
While Patkin did have his traditional garb
– loose uniform, sideways hat, and goofy
expression – it wasn’t a costume per say,
so he wasn’t the first there.
The first live costumed mascots were probably
Mr. Met in baseball and Brutus Buckeye in
college football, both debuting in 1964.
But it was a chicken that plucked his way
into American hearts and made the idea of
a costumed mascot a staple of sporting events.
It all started as a cartoon.
In 1974, the San Diego rock station KGB hired
cartoonist Brian Narelle (who would also star
in John Carpenter’s first movie Dark Star)
to create a character for a series of commercials.
He drew a chicken…
It was such a hit that the radio station created
a colorful chicken costume to go along with
it, one that debuted on Easter handing out
eggs at the San Diego Zoo.
In need of a person to go inside of the costume,
they found a journalism student paid two dollars
an hour (about $11.40 today) for the gig.
His name was Ted Giannoulas.
He was so good at being the chicken he was
asked to come to Padre games to entertain
the crowds.
Thus began an over forty year career as the
most influential mascot in American sports
history – the San Diego Chicken.
Dancing, goofing off and emerging from eggs,
many credit the Chicken and Giannoulas for
creating the modern mascot.
Influenced by the chicken, other sports teams
created mascots to promote and cheer on their
teams.
In 1977, the Phillie Phanatic (designed by
the same person who created Miss Piggy) made
his debut.
The Oriole Bird hatched a year later in Baltimore.
By the mid-1980s, many baseball, football,
soccer, college athletic teams across the
globe had dancing, costumed mascots.
Even the Olympics had their own mascots starting
in 1968 (the 1984 Los Angeles Olympics was
the first to have a living, costumed mascot).
Today, seemingly every pro, college and high
school sports team has a mascot.
There’s even a Mascot Hall of Fame, which
is in the midst of opening a brand new facility
in 2017 in Whiting, Indiana.
And they owe it all to rampant superstition
among sporting enthusiasts and athletes along
with a rather obscure 1880s French opera about
a curious virginal good luck charm- all culminating
in a gyrating banana slug being a thing
to celebrate.